young christophe duda ties the match
we're jumping into this one because it's
dramatic for liam lee against ali reza
fruga if
the young frenchman wins this game he
will win the match liam lee
he uh needs at least a draw with the
black pieces and the game has started
what are we watching yeah so it's a very
trendy variation of the spanish opening
the roy lopez
seems like all the top players now are
playing this position from white and
from black and this bishop uh kind of
sorty here by black it does invite white
to challenge in the center immediately
starting with this pawn push white is
likely to hit this bishop there we go
it's gonna take a step back
and uh here there's a multitude there's
a variety of plans for white farouza i
know has played this position as black
himself
uh this opening at least uh including
against magnus carlsen so farousa
extremely
um experienced in this type of situation
white now will just try to solidify his
center those two white pawns in the
middle of the board they just look great
whereas liam as black will try to
challenge
that structure i i've also just seen i
don't know we don't jump to other games
but um magnus's first move he's back at
it again he's gonna he's gone for one a3
which is
maybe a move to try and tilt hands it's
basically like maybe you know because he
knows hans is very uh obviously
emotional and he's basically i think
he's going to be playing a move like
that to basically you know try to put
him off kilter so i just thought that
was worth mentioning because it is a
very uh
very peculiar first move uh you know to
play
um so yeah magnus looks cool but maybe
if we can get a picture on hans hans is
he smiling is he
is he annoyed by that move i mean if
someone played it against me i would
feel they're not respecting me yeah
but uh okay hans looks relatively
focused that's good that's a good sign
for the american he'll try to punish
magnus a bit later and uh maybe if we
show this on the board i would love to
see what what is uh the idea with a
three
not too many ideas
it's gonna be said it's just a surprise
weapon is pushing a pawn on the side of
the board we've seen magnus throughout
the tour play f3 he's played uh h4 he's
played almost every move under the sun
but um one a3 the reason this is frowned
upon is it just doesn't occupy the
center it doesn't really contribute
it's not as if you're trying to open up
your rook on this line um it's not as if
this pawn this square is that important
right now but uh the game continued
hands just occupying the center very
natural and white doing the same so
basically magnus is saying okay we're
playing a queen's pawn opening but with
colours reversed uh so here i've just
got the extra move a3 which can't hurt
too much so magnus is basically trying
to play black but he's got this one
extra move uh-huh do you think he's been
following the results today all of the
winners have had the black pieces so now
he kind of with the white pieces wants
to play on the black side yeah maybe
he's just throwing away his first move
advantage he's a good psychological
psychological player i mean i have to
say as david mentioned it's not that bad
you know i remember in the early 2000s
you know that i was having conversations
with the french grandmaster eric priest
and he was always saying you know this
was his favorite move oh and he was
saying it's not that bad yeah but he was
it's mental that bad but it's not that
good either
you even wrote articles about it so i
mean i mean you can write an article
about anything right i mean it doesn't
mean it's good i mean
it's a move isn't it
but it can't give white an advantage i
suppose is the point yeah but maybe it
doesn't make white's position worse
though either
yeah i mean magnus has played some far
worse moves this tournament i mean one
f3 is very weakening yeah for example
but i think the reason we're slightly
surprised is because we would never
teach someone new to the game new to
chess to push a pawn on the side of the
board we would say occupy the center
it's only when you reach grandmaster
level or or very high levels that you
can kind of freestyle and get away with
this type of stuff on a consistent basis
like magnus does
yeah you will be punished if you don't
occupy the center in every game if you
don't develop your pieces castle the
king
because eventually you'll come under
some attack you need to know when to
break the rules and when to follow them
essentially but magnus yeah
psychologically it's really interesting
we can't be too critical
uh let's see how hans reacts meanwhile
this game between ferruga and liam
it has slowed down slightly liam is the
first one to pause and think because
furuga's kind of
this pin that he's created with his dart
squad bishop now on the edge of the
board towards the black knight and the
black queen that is very uncomfortable
and the acid test of this concept is to
try and kick away this bishop even
further but that would be very weakening
and liam i think is hesitant to weaken
the black king at the moment at least
what do you guys think of this opening
yeah i used i played it once upon a time
you know i i decided that i was not
going to play the caracon anymore i was
going to learn how to play something and
uh i was introduced to this opening and
i didn't know at the time that this was
like the sharpest
opening there was around so i just kind
of like merrily like memorize my lines
and i also remember from those times
that yeah you do have to kick away that
bishop
and
i can say that i actually just
completely gave it up after i got
smashed i got totally smashed
by a natasha boykovic a strong woman
ground master and i did not have a
chance whatsoever she came onto the
teeth with preparation and after that i
thought that's not fair i don't want to
lose games like that so back to the
caracan it was
yeah this as you mentioned it's the
sharpest line of any king's pawn opening
these days um i know a few other players
who play this on a consistent basis
going jones an english grandmaster and
i mean he's had to memorize
probably 25 moves of theory in 10
different lines just to get away with uh
this type of opening and
it gives good results if you know what
you're doing with black black's position
black's opening very good has brought
alex ishirov another famous grandmaster
some great results but
um yeah i don't i don't know personally
i'm not willing as well to kind of walk
into my opponent's homework i'd be
scared that their computer is stronger
than mine their computers offered up
some interesting suggestions that i
haven't studied sounds like their
computer will be better than yours at
the moment
talking about computers i mean i just
had a look at the evaluation and the
move suggested by the computer the
computer says only one move oh black to
kind of maintain equality and that is
simply to pick up the pawn in front of
the king
move it two squares attack the bishop
but that is really really weakening
and there we see stockfish's moves um
ivanka's computer i think is uh maybe
even stronger than this so black's best
move as we see that is uh pushing the
pawn to the g5 square maybe even giving
black decent chances but um yeah that's
not the move a human wants to play the
black king will never be safe for the
rest of the game and especially if
you're liam and you see farouza has not
blinked he's not spent a second on his
clock really he's even gained time um
you don't really want to play such a
risky move against a well-prepared
opponent and uh here white has a couple
of options i guess your anchor either
you could step back with the bishop or
maybe more ambitiously you could even
sacrifice a piece i'm not sure whether
this works or not but after a capture
here this is an eternal pin
and uh you really need to know what
you're doing to survive this type of
position i mean there's plenty of plans
here the rook could lift and swing
across to start attacking the black king
and
i would be terrified as black here
i have to show you what the computer is
actually suggesting as a top choice for
white he's actually suggesting instead
of capturing the the pawn it's actually
bishop takes knight okay bishop takes
knight first first and then after bishop
takes bishop okay and we are going to
see it and then the queen will make a
small little move quincy one and uh yeah
hitting this bishop also keeping an eye
on this diagonal and uh for example if
the bishop moves now
i mean this is going to be even more
deadly a sacrifice and look at this
would we would see
a massacre the black king
yeah this would end the game immediately
so
i've got another little rule now
i'm never playing this opening as black
in my life
it's far too much to learn and
far too scary so i'm getting my little
rules now and we're seeing it on the
board actually so uh i mean just by the
speed with which uh ferruga is playing
making the moves i'm thinking that he's
seen this before yeah he's analyzed this
with a computer and he knows exactly
what to do yeah but what could be the
reason liam lay is entering this because
he knows a loss means he loses the match
yeah i mean it's a must-win situation
first of all so it's risky he could lose
quickly but if he survives then maybe he
has decent long-term chances but also it
is part of his repertoire i've seen him
play this on the tour before this season
and uh
i mean first of all that actually makes
you a sitting duck it makes you a target
if you've played it before your opponent
can prepare something special that's why
it's so scary i think me simon ivanka i
don't think we'll be touching this
opening as black there's just too much
to know
but
it is part of his repertoire and he has
had good results with this opening
in the past liam so
i mean if i've had good results with an
opening i want to play it again even if
my opponents can come up with something
even if they prepare something special
but
survival is not guaranteed that's the
one problem here and we are expecting to
see as stockfish says uh in front of us
on our screens the white queens sidestep
one square but even the other moves uh
that the computer mentions the immediate
sacrifice of the white knight that we
showed opening up the black king
that looks very very tempting and very
scary as well for black i'd love to be
white in these positions because uh
they're very natural moves as well i
mean uh you're opening up your
opponent's king probably to not too much
risk um it's not a do or die sacrifice
because you got like okay he's playing
he knows this stuff
and the other i guess the other thing to
bear in mind is that um ali raza was for
usual he was playing in the candidates
so he's got that candidate's preparation
that some of the other players may not
have he spent months and months
preparing and something like this could
well have been uh in his preparation for
the candidates um so you know who he's
working with well he was working before
the candidates with uh kramnik aha i
don't think that's happening anymore
after the interview probably uh as an
amazing interview wasn't there i mean uh
that was drawing the candidates and
kramnik was
uh reporting on some of the games and uh
one of uh ferocious games i think he
said
he was just very um i don't know very
critical about his play shall we say i
can't remember exact words but it was uh
along the lines that this was incredibly
weak game by you know he's supposed to
and he was helping him as well so it's
very surprising
what he said i mean he's probably been
honest with his opinion but it was yeah
it's
interesting to hear i guess but i i've
seen some pictures of uh maximum vagiela
grav in miami actually he's the
frenchman is there any rumors he's
working with fergia the frenchman
teaming up yeah i mean it's unconfirmed
rumors but i've heard
from some of the other players uh in uh
in miami that they think maybe there's
some collaboration going on with the two
frenchmen there and it's noticeable that
vashey legrov and faruja who now played
for france neither of them played the
olympiad that's true so maybe they were
studying together maybe they were
working together and
it would be too much of a coincidence
surely for them both to be in miami at
the same time don't you say that but i
have to say you know
in maxim's defense you know he actually
told me in during norway chess that uh
he was going to be in miami
coincidentally
just to uh visit france oh whether that
was just kind of
just for one week just for the dates uh
15th to 21st august
i'm also wondering why they didn't play
the olympiad i mean i'm sure there's
some reason there but i mean it's big
surprise really well
top two players don't play this actually
maxine marshall graph did tell me the
reason why i mean it was just simply um
he was going to play valley reza played
which i actually i realized is adding
fuel to the fire that they're they're
working together
but since ali reza said no i mean he
thought about it he thought the weather
would be perhaps too hot for him so he
goes to miami instead
yeah that makes sense
well we do have a bunch of moves on the
board david are you surprised by
anything happening here um it's along
the lines of what we predicted but we
will explain a bit later yeah because
we're talking about helpers and seconds
and coaches and there are a few of them
in miami young pregnant and he had a
great day yesterday he won his match
against ali reza farusia today he's
playing against aneesh giri and in miami
as always his coach is with him and
right now he's also with zlata
yes i'm sitting here with ramess right
now and
you were just telling me hero master
prank is still in its preparation is
that correct yeah um
i hope it's safe to say yeah reveal it
now
but but but it's uh it's it's been quite
the journey for him because yesterday it
was all the deciding games and today
it's two games that probably should have
been decided
yeah in the first game uh
prague completely forgot the preparation
right in the opening after anish played
the castle and they got into a mess
as alias mutant and for a very long time
he was in a big mess and even though
anisha also did not
react properly at many moments gave a
counter play to prague and it ended in a
draw so that was a good escape
because losing first game with the white
would have been a disaster so good save
and the second game
again got the preparation after queen a7
bb7
he should have continued better not gone
for the a3 pawn and he would have got a
clearly better position should have gone
for a kingston attack
uh so it's uh
both the game's uh ending in a draw
itself in a very fair result i would say
when it comes to the location here i
mean
i i must know i mean we are sitting at a
quite interesting area we're on miami
beach you guys are used to this kind of
heat because today it is 100 degrees
fahrenheit it's 36 degrees celsius it's
humidity of 80 percent
does this just feel like a normal day to
you yeah very normal
so
from where we come chennai it's either
hot hotter or the hottest so this should
be in the middle so you're saying that
prague probably has a massive advantage
to his other players with this golden
heat yeah yes a big weather advantage i
would say
but we are oddly dressed to be in a
swimming pool
well i'm definitely going in that
swimming pool quite soon i think
when it comes to to the ambitions for
this tournament what do you expect from
prague going further further in the last
uh event at oslo he was leading for a
very large part of the event and they
finished
the fourth after losing the last two
matches
but we hope to do better this time and
he has had a
good start defeating alireza even though
in a very
lopsided match
i'm
very optimistic
right now we've had a really hard time
working here so i think that we should
settle down by the pool side for a
little bit sit back and relax and uh
kaya cheers from miami eden rock hotel
we are signing out
i'm not jealous at all sitting here with
my cup of coffee oh you lucky guys that
looks amazing and interesting to hear
from the great ramesh talking about
prague
aiming
to win the ftx crypto cup in miami the
young 17 year old and another youngster
the 19 year old ali reza faruza who lost
to pragnanda yesterday but now he is
fighting to win the match against liam
lee with a win in this game he will
decide the match and take all three
points and the bar has definitely gone
over to his side david what's happening
yeah it just looks like uh great opening
preparation from perugia has helped him
get a decently sized advantage and the
nature of the game has changed since we
last left so let's jump in
to explain what has happened we left it
here where white's queen had attacked
this bishop also eyeing up this diagonal
black's bishop did indeed move it
captured a pawn in the center there's
thunder above us again and after the
white knight captured
there's thunder on the board just
temporarily it looks very scary for
black but at least the black bishop now
can jump back and defend and at the very
end white is a piece down but he
captures the knight and after the queen
trade if we do a quick count white has
an extra pawn there's a three versus one
advantage on this side of the board
and uh on the other side black has four
versus three but those four aren't
motoring any time soon and just a couple
more moves black's rook moving
and now a pawn push stopping the white
knight from jumping forward and
it is a pawn black has the two bishops
as compensation but it's hard to imagine
the two bishops being too great in this
position white's bishop meanwhile is
actually a fantastic piece um ferruga
here pushes forward with central pawn
and black blocks
at some point i'm expecting these pawns
to start motoring forward and really
causing some problems to black on the
king side
what do you guys think
any compensation here for black the
computer gives plus one because i guess
white does have an extra pawn after all
i mean at least black has a poor
majority on the queen side um this is
similar to like uh you can sometimes get
in the bononi opening
and that poor majority can be dangerous
later on if if black can push them down
the board he's going to get past pawn
and with the bishop protecting it
there's you know just maybe some counter
play but
at the end of the day is is a pawn up
and white's pawns on the king's side
looks look much more scarier
especially with that really powerful
dark square bishop around the black king
so certainly white's better but it's not
completely over for for black in in my
opinion yeah i i there is some chances
for black to save the position
but i have to say i mean it's looking
really unlikely right you know because
i just love that monster bishop that
white has i mean
just look at it it's just such a thorn
and black side
and as david's highlighting the knight's
going to jump forward the pawns are
going to start
motoring
but you know i always say if you're
defending a position you should always
look for the positives and you should
never ever lose hope so i'm going to go
with simon's answer because that fits my
philosophy i just think the computer's
given quite an interesting move as well
actually which
you know um glancing over is
saying the black bishop can attack that
rook and maybe things are not too bad
actually if you can play this move okay
um
with the idea you've got a pawn push and
those pawns suddenly become mobile
in some situations so uh you know
causes discomfort at least yeah white's
rook cannot move it has to stay
defending like he doesn't play it the
rook has to stay defending the night and
uh simon mentions you can at least gain
time
uh kick away this bishop if it goes back
uh then yeah maybe you start motoring
forward with these pawns but instead uh
liam chooses a different uh a different
move an alternative he parks his rook in
the center also very logical he guards
this square taking the square away from
the white knight
and he does threaten to double up his
rooks along the e file
this would be a bit scary so how does
farouza deal with this
the two moves that kind of call out to
me immediately one is to move the knight
to attack this rook but i'm not sure
whether a rook trade helps also i'm a
bit reluctant to let the rook kick my
bishop away from its dream outpost
um yeah this one is slightly tempting
the other move is this pawn push but
then again it does allow black at some
point to kind of open up with a check
gaining time so uh pros and cons behind
both those ideas for russia though he
has to guard against blacks rooks
doubling up
on the e-file not so clear is that yeah
that means at all actually it looks a
lot clearer earlier when uh frugia was
just attacking getting his preparation
in but i i think this is
good what liam lee's done
because uh he got tricked in the theory
and he's found the position where he's
worse but he can at least play
and and he won't get crushed immediately
which is always nice so there's there's
some chances here i think that's good
psychology because i think at some point
or rather we all get out prepared we all
know less than our opponents in the
opening and number one it's just number
one goal is just to survive right and
also to keep some advantages you might
be pawn down but you do have the two
bishops long term as you mentioned you
do have this poor majority on the queen
side
something to hold on to something to
play for long term and psychologically
it's always also difficult for the for
the player here for roger who has
prepared 20 moves to suddenly switch uh
into kind of thinking for themselves
farouza will know okay the computer gave
him plus one uh after the opening he
knows the opening went well but to
figure out why for himself that won't be
too easy so okay we do see this pawn
push kicking away the black rook and a
check
discover check to the white king
it was played very quickly by liam
and uh okay the king moves
one of the downsides of that pawn push
actually is that the rook has to
actually vacate the fourth row and this
means that maybe the white knight can
step into its ideal square yeah i'm not
sure which way it goes probably this way
just to hit the bishop and to stop any
potential
checks
yeah now the bishop would love to come
here and give a check when it can be
eliminated by the white knight this is
actually
this position is on the board
and yeah we talked about the two bishops
if white can make this exchange that
would make his life a lot easier if he
could also trade one set of rooks then
he's one step closer to converting his
extra bond
long term what does liam have in store
here
i suppose the first move you calculate
is can you still play that check
um and we know how
how good at calculating frugal is so i'm
sure he's got this one covered um but
okay this has to be taken you take with
a pawn and maybe it's a little bit murky
here i mean
that pawn is only two squares away from
queening so
it's
it might just be weak as well though it
might just be captured and i think it is
probably weak here but uh
you can certainly consider this one
first something along these lines the
black pawn if it could stay i mean if
black just had one extra move activate
the rook then he's doing well but yeah
the question is how do you keep this
pawn alive yeah potentially um if it
marches forward maybe the bishop can
come back and eliminate it so it's
something along these lines you're right
simon um that are going through
uh liam's mind right now he's gonna
calculate can you give a check uh if not
can you at least keep this bishop alive
maybe you can move it and the type of
move i want one i would want to play in
the game is just to annoy the opponent
just kind of put the bishop
right next to them in the white camp
just say okay you kick me out
if you can but if not then the bishop
might survive okay he chooses a
different square
he keeps the bishop alive here instead
the reason i was reluctant is at some
point you might get kicked by a pawn but
this isn't possible yet uh if white's
pawn steps forward then the other pawn
drops with a check
so okay decent move by liam now
how does farouza just continue his
mission to try and trade off pieces
not easy actually still
if you trade a set of rooks then the
white knight is uh actually not on a
stable square i just have to tell you i
i am cheating i i'm looking at
carlson neiman again am i allowed to do
that
just have a little little glance look at
the bar in that one look at the bar
there i know
black it's a it's a day of black
victories and and neiman is well
according to the computer has a sizable
advantage against magnus in that game so
i i just you know i wanted to mention
that because it's been a fascinating
match as well so oh it's gonna come down
to the last game whatever though so we
know that whatever the result in this
game we get one more game uh um at least
in in this one so uh very interesting
stuff there but great that you're
keeping an eye on that simon and if you
know
if you feel we should go over to that
game then you let us know we can always
do that well he may have just let all
his advantage slip so uh it could have
been a brief a brief one there
but i mean obviously the the frugal game
is very exciting as well but it's just
nice to keep an eye on that that you
know that that encounter as well but has
a vantage tip i'm not sure it's too much
for me to look at quickly i i don't know
a very complicated game there but
neiman's doing the right thing he is
trying to punish magnus for that kind of
slightly unorthodox first move and look
at magnus's body language not happy at
all yeah um hans neiman i can see on his
screen as well he's got a pre-move ready
just in case magnus trades a set of
queens interesting not even looking
confident and uh clock times in that one
if we can look in on the screen
and let's see it looks like
three minutes for hans nine minutes for
magnus ah so
that's maybe one hazard for uh neiman
imagine if neiman wins that one i mean
uh we've got to get an interview haven't
we yeah because he's going to run out of
cash phrases
you know we need an interview either way
whatever there is definitely we do yeah
yeah i mean he hasn't had any draws this
tournament i wonder what he'd say after
a draw
yeah yeah yeah maybe he'll repeat uh
what he said before the chest speaks for
itself yeah yeah
and uh walk away walk away well i'll be
disappointed i feel he needs a new
catchphrase right yeah yeah he's got it
yeah
kind of he's better than that he's
better than that hands will give us
something unique i'm sure
so uh yeah definitely okay yeah
meanwhile in this game between ferruccia
and liam um sometimes especially when i
was younger i used to like to solve
puzzles they called them self-mates or
help mates and here white could get
checkmated if he's not careful um it
would be a bit of a silly move but if we
just jump in uh while farouz is thinking
long think now if white's knight were to
retreat which is a bad move for a few
reasons suddenly checkmate in two moves
i just wanted to show this
uh rook takes pawn sacrifice hitting the
king and now the bishop comes in swoops
in
bowdoin's mouth that is the bowden is it
bowden's mate yeah okay
checkmate on the board so or the
crisscross the crisscross yeah
i mean this would be a very pretty way
to end the game uh i don't think ferrus
is going to fall for it but that just
just to highlight the danger
that does face the frenchman right now
did you find david doing doing um i know
jabarva a very strong player mentioned
that doing studies was the way that he
he
improved the most because nowadays most
people just concentrate on openings and
of course openings is important but i do
honestly think openings are overstudied
um quite quite you know majority of
books that are made on chess it's
something like 92 percent of all books
on chess are opening books but in actual
fact i think other areas of the game
more important but do you think uh
studying doing studies is a great way to
improve or
as well definitely yeah i mean i would
say two things uh that really helped
boost my game i mean one was doing
puzzles um just general tactical puzzles
for example
it would be a position like this it's
like oh spot the mate in two for black
you always look for checks captures and
threats first if the checks work then
great
checks could be very effective you could
end up checkmating the opponent
captures work you might win material
threats you might trap your opponent but
you're right simon end game studies so
not quite this position perhaps but uh
just general end games where you have to
calculate deeply i noticed that i was
around 2600 rating for
what was it six or seven years and then
when i left university i decided okay
i'm going to work on my chest more
seriously i did a lot of end game
studies
guided by
a few other players and they said okay
study like this
calculate like this and suddenly i hit
within a year i hit 2 700 and
um it doesn't sound like much but it was
a boost it was kind of breaking the next
hand how did you get to 2600 though
that's like can we do that first step
first
no idea that was just lucky that's just
natural
oh dear i mean uh yeah i mean it's the
same at any level it's not about the
rating it's just if you reach a plateau
then i think the next step is to force
yourself to calculate every time and
um i think that's why i get away with
like other deficiencies in my game being
in time trouble sometimes
not always being so great in the opening
i can calculate my way out of trouble
because i study those those types of
things
and i think that's why the young players
of today the new generation are so great
they're so scary because they're so good
at calculating and they
we saw ramesh chilling out on the sun
bed there just with this cocktail but i
know for a fact that he gives his
students end-game studies all the time
oh i think they solve puzzles like that
daily
long difficult variations they have to
calculate 10 moves 15 moves to the head
in their minds and it works
and his philosophy i mean he's just
published a book you know on test
calculation and his philosophy his chest
is hard you've got a use and exercise
those gray matter you know and just
it is a difficult game and you have to
be as precise as you can and where he
were you can you know he actually
encourages blindfold visualization oh
that you start with a position on the
board and then every line that you
calculate you know has to be in your
head
and uh
you've got to be as precise as possible
because this is going to help you
in those uh critical moments yeah
yeah and i mean ramesh is an example of
um some i mean he's a grandmaster he's a
very strong player but uh he can even
help the elite players who are now maybe
a hundred points 200 points stronger
than him because he he knows how to
study chess and how to kind of structure
your own thinking with uh in-game
studies so yeah that's a really good
point simon
yeah i think it's very interesting i
think a lot of people forget how hard
chess is
and a lot of people who take up chess
they
they they don't appreciate that actually
to become as good as anywhere near as
good as these guys
requires a lot of work and a lot of
dedication
and a lot of solving stuff as well you
can't rely on uh just to get better by
watching the odd youtube video or
something you've got to think for
yourself
and that is something people forget you
know we talk about geniuses but uh
there's a lot of work behind that
geniusness i guess i think there's a
maid not born yeah that's that's that's
it that's what judith pogba says isn't
it geniuses are made and not born i
think she she comes back to that a lot
from her own upbringing but
yeah and also looking at the game david
i i is this turning maybe in this gotta
say you know hasn't white got themselves
in a bit of a tangle yeah trust me i
mean if anyone i would pick black as
well i guess you guys too yeah yeah i
mean black's past porn
which the pawn that's about to come and
pass porn is much more dangerous than
any pawn that white has two bishops it's
uh it's actually uh quite scary for
fruga now yeah and especially after this
move which looks a bit superficial
somehow he just moved his rook across
two moves ago now he has moved it back
where it came from and he's just
terrified of this pawn which uh he's
right to be but uh okay how can black
defend this pawn you guys are right if
you can somehow march this down two
squares where it's protected from uh by
the bishop from afar then black is gonna
win the game uh so you just need to kind
of there's like a barricade right now
this square is covered by three white
pieces by a pawn a rook and a bishop so
you need to get it past
this kind of maybe you can re-route that
bishop yeah so
okay the bishop actually now is on a
good square
because those two bishops when they find
these they're going to be very
dangerously pointing towards white's
king it's clever simon yeah i mean
you're right i mean if you get one more
move suddenly um we showed one checkmate
earlier with the two bishops but this
kind of laser-like vision this is
it's terrifying i definitely prefer
black now um actually
maybe we can get the stockfish the
computer suggestions up on the screen
because um this one is not easy
retreating moves are not obvious at all
but there we go it is the best move by
far simon this one this one gives black
the advantage anything else gives white
the advantage
so dropping the bishop back teaming it
up with its mate over here
and the whole idea is rook takes pawn is
met by a pin
and uh you pin and you definitely win
here
this just looks scary i'm surprised it
only gives
0.7 for black to be honest after this
bishop retreat i'm not sure where white
can put the king this is this is the
problem the position the white king does
it have any any safe squares i was
wondering whether you could actually do
the same kind of idea you know black has
gone backwards with the bishop maybe the
white knight can now re-route itself go
back to where it came from and then when
the bishop comes then you can just jump
into the center but uh perhaps
this is perhaps just simply saying
there's no advantage whatsoever just
trying to head towards the drawer or
something but
you know still some play there actually
i think you're right ivanka maybe that's
one of the only ways to stop white's
king coming under fire
but for example if black does find this
really this star move if liam finds it
now um a backward knight move it's not
the most obvious idea in the position
white's knight looks pretty nice so i
think it's actually going to be very
difficult just visually for for russia
to find a night retreat
yeah i mean if liam plays this one i
think he's actually a favorite in
practical terms at least
so okay big moment in the current
position william finds the idea of
rerouting his bishop back
and oh he doesn't he plays the second
best move according to stockfish there
but he gives a check but now the two
bishops are gone
knight takes bishop has been played
and he's recaptured with his pawn so
something similar to what you showed
earlier simon this is a very scary pawn
but it's one dimensional for black if
this pawn doesn't save or win you the
game then
yeah it's over you'll just lose
yeah
now white does have several promising
options as well according to stockfish
okay will white just trade rooks which
is actually very sensible
will white for example just ignore it
and push his pawn forward that's what
the computer wants uh as a second choice
okay for roger now things are easier to
calculate he does find the most accurate
idea and if the black pawn pushes you
don't capture the black rook because
black makes a queen instead of course
you just move your rook across and this
pawn is doomed
can't save it anymore
yeah i was wondering whether whether
liam could be a bit flashy and maybe try
to protect that pawn from a different
angle and maybe push his b pawn and try
and keep the game alive that way but uh
probably not as
yeah with the idea to keep the pawn
alive here yeah
i guess a big big threat now you want to
come and check and remove the defender
and promote the black pawn but at the
very least i guess white can bring his
bishop back and just if we see more
trades the problem is we did this count
earlier white has the three versus one
on the king side so no matter what
happens on the rest of the board long
term the three will beat the one and the
more pieces that disappear the more
important that factor becomes
i don't know suddenly liam missing that
golden opportunity of retreating his
bishop i think he might have blown it
yeah and if he loses this game he's out
off today anyway not out of the whole
thing but he he loses this uh mini match
so it's a very very important
game for him but
it looks it looks like he's he's heading
heading to a loss now yeah the white
king is just doing a great job it's
within what we call the box so the box
is when an opponent's past pawn is
coming down but you kind of draw a line
down to its uh
kind of start square you draw a line
across and this is the box and the white
king is within touching distance of this
pawn uh so it will
always save the day and this pawn push
has happened the rook does slide across
i think we'll see ivanka's variation
there we are heading in that way
we'll see a catcher now from frugia this
pawn is too dangerous to be left alive
i assume and then after capture we'll
see this variation of the bishops
getting traded and we will see a rook
and game where white has an extra pawn
these two will eventually win
the game for forum
are you that certain now
yeah yes i mean rook and games they have
some george tendencies but
i can't see miracles happening in this
one unfortunately for liam
and then not only win him in the game
but the match aliens of russia who lost
yesterday so this will be a big match
win for him if he is able to
beat liam who also lost his match
yesterday to lavon aronian so a bad
start to the ftx crypto cup for liam lay
but fuji making his debut this season on
the melt water champions chess tour he's
finally getting in the groove and we
know what a fantastic
chess player and especially online and
rapid chess player he can be are we
seeing starting to see now the best of
ferocia
i think by the end of this tournament we
will be seeing the best of him um
obviously yesterday was a bit tricky um
in the end he just he was unlucky in
here and he couldn't
kind of convert that advantage against
prague but yeah if he wins this one he's
also a form player if he gets on a roll
he's hard to stop yeah as i found out at
the isle of at the grand swiss last year
he was on a roll winning all his games
and then i've met him
he
took me down so he mentioned that in uh
the greetings video where he
congratulated you on mayor olympic gold
he said something about the tournament
on the isle of man they said he wished
you could have played more games yeah it
was a really dramatic game it was a big
time scramble i found a really clever
resource but he yeah he was just too
strong in the end he saw he calculated
more than me and that's how he qualified
for the candidates uh if i'd won it
would have been the other way around but
yeah i'd love to get a chance against
him but i'm scared that he's kind of
going in one direction
i think he'll have his uh his sights set
higher
i once played a 50-game blitz marathon
with him online 50-game 50-game
in total
oh
wow how long did that last a few hours
good few hours
remember to score um i think he beat me
by about 10 points overall so that's not
bad because he's very
bullet i guess as well yeah uh it was
blitz blitz okay
bullet i have no chance he's one of the
fastest hands in the west
yeah
and we have reached this rook in game
where white does have four versus three
but it's more important than the white
pawns on the king side the right side
they are connected
and it's liam who needs to be faster he
only has a little over one minute
left on his clock yeah
and
while things are not looking great for
liam but he is in survival mode
and uh
okay ferrous making some stepping
forward with the king and when will they
start pushing those white pawns that
david highlighted
probably now probably now as soon as
possible but i mean he has to be careful
the only thing that i would say is that
when you start advancing those pawns
you've got to do it as a team you know
you have to remember that word teamwork
makes a dream work and you know back
those pawns up with the king you know
have them advance slowly and steady it
wins the race for sure and uh it's also
about mobilizing the work at the right
time so
but the if you do all those things the
result is pretty much inevitable yeah
and i like what ferris is doing he's got
time on the clock and he's pausing he's
uh kind of just working out that he can
connect all the pawns step them up in a
safe way i like what he's doing compared
to what duda did in the last game where
duda had 10 seconds and he kind of
rushed and nearly let the wind slip
so far janelle
i i guess he's going to just advance
either the white king or the white pawns
in some kind of order but there they go
and
i like starting with that one it's the
middle pawn and it will be supported by
both pawns from the side as well uh the
white king has a nice say square behind
that pawn as well
and uh okay black's king stepping
forward
liam's doing the right thing you have to
go active with one piece black's rook is
passive just defending pawns so black's
king
has been tasked with uh going towards
the center
you know what else to do liam is uh he's
just gonna confuse foruger here somehow
black's majority black only has one past
pawn that's the a pawn and it's kept
under lock and key by the white rook
right now so he wants to somehow
distract or deflect away the white rook
so that that black apron can start
running
but i don't think black is actually
threatening to come in with a king
unfortunately because that pawn can be
defended by the white rook putting
itself on the
a5 square yeah so uh i think he just has
to disregard that threat not get scared
by anything
and uh he deals with the threat actually
by pushing his f-form forward
and uh liam steps forward with rook gets
the rook active why not
mike king's a bit more exposed now
though a bit surprised he pushed that
pawn
as in now the black rock has has more
checks it's probably still very grim
but um he doesn't have a safer square
for the king and maybe basically now
right you know because i was kind of
advocating that you kind of marched
together with your pawns as a group um i
was surprised that he let his king
potentially be cut off but uh farouja
has the faith in his pawns he's just
gonna push him
it's probably still just winning isn't
it quite quite
just by pushing them yeah they are
connected after all still yeah they
protect each other so the white king can
kind of have freedom to start dancing
forward at some point white's rook is
quite nicely placed to be honest just
stopping black central pawn from
advancing just pinning it
um
yeah i mean it's just a question of
whether ferugia can go straight for the
kill by pushing his pawns even further
up the ward or whether he remaneuvers
the white king or the white rook first
all right well we could have the first
white win in today's matches and not
only in this game but look at the bar in
the game between pragnanda and giri two
draws between them so far but in game
three the bar just jumped up for
pragnanda against anish giri he could be
about to take the lead in this match
young pregnant on that trouble for
aneesh geary and magnus carlsen against
hans niemann as well the bar has jumped
up now four magnus crossing in what
seems to be a very interesting game
these two are tied after two games they
won one game each and magnus could be
about to take the lead now in the match
otherwise roja however he can decide the
match if he wins this game and the bar
is also all the way over to his side in
this game is it getting close yes i
actually quite like his last rook move
you guys were worried about checks
against the white king but the white
rook keeps
everything nice and safe he's playing
slow and steady right now for roger he's
not taking too many risks with the white
pawns and yeah
i was just going to say one move that
white perhaps maybe should not do
it
certainly not take it lightly is
actually push the pawn forward and give
the king a check because this will
encourage the black king to come forward
yeah that's actually probably the reason
he played his last move ivanka this
check would allow the black king to get
active and maybe still winning uh maybe
you're still quite quick with your pawns
but now you the margin for error has
been lessened suddenly your pawns might
start to fall so
okay he moved his rook up cutting the
black king across on this line and if we
catch up with the current position just
a few moves later white has kind of
trapped the black brook down on this
square and maybe now is the time now
that the black king can no longer
take a step forward now maybe the time
to check
wherever the black king goes you can
start marching the white king forward
kind of it's got a safe haven here
this looks pretty straightforward okay
for roger again not taking any risk at
all uh instead of giving the check he
drops his rook back he's going to put
his rook behind the past pawn also good
strategy in rook and games and then
he'll propel the pawn forward any rook
in game any rook trades here will just
win for white
so
yeah maybe
nice and steady yeah i'm a bit gutted
actually that um they had the
competition yesterday
um where you had to pick the winner for
the crypto key yeah which i hope
everyone at home did because it was 15
000
and i said prague and i'm really now
going for my brain i didn't get it in
silly me because i was working too hard
here of course of course we should give
you a second chance yeah i should have a
second chance but i'm wondering how many
people actually bet on prague to win
because i could have won like a serious
amount of money there so i'm really
interested you know this is the crypto
cup and people should investigate
there's loads of cool free stuff that
people can sign up for there but how
many people prague to win because he's a
good bet i think you know just
too many people will i don't think so
not as many as carson or something so it
might you know
i'll ask i'll ask yeah the people in
congress i don't want to know now
i don't want to know how much i could
have won so like okay and he said prague
how many said magnus you know how many
said remember
the ones who answer correctly they share
fifteen thousand dollars which is a
great price and
remember also to claim your free fdx
crypto cup key
it's a great way to join in all the fun
of the ftx summer of chess and uh a
bunch of prizes a bunch of cool content
if you get claim your key and uh join
the discord community for the ftx crypto
cup and alley reservoir maybe someone
also answered him because he is a
fantastic chess player and he could be
about
to win the match after only three games
here against liam
he should still be winning the white
king now going across to deal with
black's
remaining hope that past pawn and i've
got to say simon it's the commentator's
curse the moment you started praising
prague
he let the winners
i don't know why it happens like that
any time
i say oh i'm supporting iranian the wind
slips if
it's that way i'm kind of like so i
would have i would have bet on prague
because i think it was quite a good
thing so
i really like prank but i'm kind of now
hoping he doesn't win just because i'm
being really annoyed myself so it's like
you know but um you know he could easily
win this competition i think because
he's strong enough but beating a niche
is never never simple no definitely not
easy and uh i actually went for duda
yeah
eyes on him as well so
and faruja just seems to be
playing it very effortlessly here great
uh result for him because he's just
simply gonna march his king forward
keep an eye on black's passport
and of course get on with the main job
which is to escort those pawns on the
right to the destination
and uh look at this white has the most
behaviors
[Music]
oh okay
on my computer it went down i haven't
seen the move yeah yeah
okay what has happened here so let's try
and work it out has
well has black somehow conjured up some
magic
has feroza let the wind slip what could
black be trying here it looks hopeless
white's pawns are connected whites rook
is just going to come across and deal
with black's past porn
i mean
maybe there's a miracle here somehow i
don't see it i've got to say
could it be that you know simply
what black starts destabilizing the
pawns
and gets very active with the
king or could be just the king coming
forward
what is the idea now either if white
gives a check with the pawn kicking the
black king away or if white just
moves his rook across
and bob tries to attack the black pawn
by by cheating
he said just defending the pawn
was was okay believe it or not um but
okay defending the pawn now with black
um no one moved one move before before
the king that doesn't make any sense
wow i mean maybe there was some miracle
save there but uh even if we see the
moves even if we see the best computer
moves it's hard to understand why yeah
maybe it's just the fact that white's
rook is tied down now white's rook is
passive
but now now it thinks that white's
completely winning so there's a bit of a
mystery there i think i doubt
it
and uh okay how can white win this game
it's still not easy though white is
playing without his rook
roof down under 10 seconds okay
full credit to liam for even making this
difficult okay he gives a check hitting
the black king the black king steps back
i think this is a clever choice of
square the black king has to stay within
touching distance of the white pawns
and uh what next for ferocia
no it's not easy actually for farooz i
didn't like that he kind of spoiled the
integrity of his pawns
they're no longer all connected
defending each other white king is going
after black's pawn but now the black
rook
could potentially start hitting some
pawns
who would have favored to uh get rid of
the rooks
white white will win if the rooks come
off the board okay he's tried to
challenge a set of pawns now but white
hasn't protected past pawn
uh that white g pawn okay a set of pawns
have been exchanged but that past g1 is
gonna win the game now
um this should be
enough
i mean maybe there was a miraculous draw
i'm definitely going to go back and
study that game study the same game
later
i definitely recommend everyone at home
to do the same because rook and games
they're the hardest ones to learn about
we know the general rules like active
king active rook rooks behind past pawns
but there's always exceptions
and uh okay this is a check
it's also funny that prague and anish
giri they're playing a rook game as well
slightly similar to this one oh so
where white is also a pawn up
and okay this track has forced white's
king back
again you still gotta win this position
but uh it's
white's pawns looking
very good yeah that's the key to protect
each other right so um the white king
now will go and attack that black rook i
guess
and hopefully i'm still fighting
okay a check first
and
now you need to defend your f pawn with
white
this does the job black's rook needs to
move now maybe it'll give a check
white's king will sidestep if that's the
case
there we go
and yeah you still need to win it you're
right i guess white's winning idea is to
go and attack this remaining black pawn
black's pawn is very weak after all
there we go
and then uh the only way to defend is to
move the king
got not checked something this is the
thing i mean
not enough the white king is going to
zigzag back towards the black rook and
uh i guess it will use the h file um you
don't want to get checked where black
can hit your king and your pawns at the
same time
and that f pawn is now dropping right
black's remaining porn i don't think
it's defendable okay that's
and look at that magnus crosston leaves
the arena he wins game three against
niman he takes the lead
now by one point and that means hans
niemann he has to win game four
starting in ten minutes to uh take it to
tie breaks a comeback by magnus carlsen
who lost the first game against hans
niemann today
alvarez of russia he can decide it right
now if he wins this game
and he's going the long way round with
this king but it looks good enough the
white king has gone on a journey how
does black defend his pawn the problem
is if the black king goes to defend it
then the black king will get displaced
by a nasty check
i think we'll see that happen in a
moment
we see black continue checking the white
king
no we do see
the checks would have run out and uh
this is the key move
next move white's rook does go to attack
the black
pawn we will see it
right now
the rook moved to f7 square
and that's it this game over right
unless
next that's a miracle stalemate or
something but
i think the black king has enough
squares and there we go prague and
anishigiri ended up in king versus king
wow that's a draw it was a draw three
draws so far by pragnanda and nanishkiri
tied before game four
it feels like we will see some tie
breaks today finally and hopefully young
christophe duda and levon aronian they
also played a draw and they are tied
they won one game each and one draw so
they are tied but ali reza ruja he is
about to decide this match against liam
very bad start to the tournament for
liam losing both of the two first
matches yeah and liam has set a couple
of clever traps yeah trying to work out
how to win suddenly farouza leaned
forward he realized it's not
as easy as he thought and maybe we can
keep an eye on the player we just have
to show this firstly big big trap in the
position if you get greedy and capture
this pawn then you actually lose as
white you get checked and there's a
skewer next move the white rook is lost
but even if you march your king forward
and i was going to say that you have to
be careful after a check if you go the
wrong direction
then you do blow the win you have to go
forward if you'd gone back then after
rook takes rook i think this is the draw
the black king can just step across and
now if you take this pawn it is
stalemate
so you had to avoid that pitfall but he
has gone forward instead and now rook
takes where it clearly doesn't work
because white will make a new queen
and ferocious idea is that if the black
king gives a black rook gives a check
the white king steps back and it will be
the white king that tries to take this
pawn
and that being said
a check
and this
this is a win and here white should be
careful uh well white doesn't have to be
careful here you can just go either way
with the king and black's king has to
move out the way you make a new queen
finally will we see another queen do you
think in this game or will it end before
that happens he'll resign exactly and
yeah if we go back to the current
position if you can't get away with
trading rooks if you can't get away with
a check
what else
resign resign time just resign
for the porn just get it over with
resign
no he he's he said a lot of very clever
traps and uh i've noticed this with uh
liam lacroix he's really really tricky
and he's very very determined um i mean
here um
your last punt is to maybe go for some
stalemate with these when you you're
playing against these two connected past
pawns so try to put your king in the
corner
and hope but
it's it's not it's really hard to do it
here i mean if you've got the pawns over
one more flank you've got more stale
matrix but this is
pretty trivial isn't it now and now you
can see the white king is coming to the
defense of the past pawns and this will
basically release the white rook and
allow it to just move over to the left
side and uh okay you can hide from any
checks behind your own pawns now
this is why two connected past pawns are
always winning they protect each other
they create hiding spaces for your king
from checks
and uh look no more checks now black's
king not stalemated it still has one
escape square and
it's elementary you just move the white
rook away you give a check to the black
king and there are checkmating ideas
all over the place
and there we go the evaluation bar is
going crazy yeah it's game over any
second white just needs to maybe move
his king out the way right now move his
king threaten checkmate and this will be
game over
game set and match i like that tennis
game set match there yeah
and there we go there we go it's a
result after black blocks this check a
rook trade white would win the king and
poor end game for roger takes the win
yeah